it's the first time psychologists James
Mitchell has testified in court about
his work for the CIA after September
11th and Mitchell was both combative and
proud of his work as a contract
interrogator what he called life-saving
questioning techniques lawyers for the
911 defendants called torture meaning
they shouldn't be convicted
much less executed in his mind the
coercive physical pressures which
includes but II I tease but is not
everything is the critical defining
element the fact that people are being
held in isolation for years
incommunicado from their families told
that they're going to die there and lack
all ordinary protections of a person in
prison is outrageous
Mitchell testified he waterboarded
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed and Abu Zubaydah
something he said he found upsetting but
he said stab CIA interrogators regularly
crossed the line forcing detainees to
kneel backwards with a broomstick behind
their knees depriving them of sleep food
and clothing or in the case of Amara
Bellucci letting rookie interrogators
slam him into a wall over and over for
practice both the defendants and 11
relatives of people killed in the
attacks listened to Mitchell's testimony
on Friday
they watched Mitchell and Mustafa
al-hasawi lawyer Walter Maurice tangle
over house Ali's treatment in detention
at Guantanamo I wanted to establish the
the basically triple roles that he had
right intelligence collection debriefer
and psychologists right and to
illustrate or at least lay the
foundation for why that why that is so
damaging Jim Mitchell has been trying to
show all week that he was one of the
good guys during a period of high fear
and anxiety in the United States the
military judge in this case has yet to
rule whether what Mitchell and other
interrogators did to detainees in fact
constituted torture that decision could
one day affect how both prosecutors and
the defense lawyers prepare their cases
for trial
Rosalind jordan al Jazeera Guantanamo